à l'occasion de la fête de l'internet le
gouvernement vient de prendre un décret
permettant enfin de crypter les
informations sur le web
une mesure jugée indispensable puisque
désormais de nombreuses transactions
commerciales ou informations
confidentielles provenant d'entreprises
sont diffusées sur internet
eric lemasson marcel martin cet homme
d'alluré distinguer et le butin des
règles de la toile c'est l'un des
inventeurs d'internet
autant dire que ces analyses devant 300
chefs d'entreprises françaises d'hier
peuvent être considérés comme des
prédictions
le commerce électronique explose dit il
et représentera bientôt 15 % du commerce
mondial internet remplacera téléphone
fax et lettres dans les relations
contractuelles entre les entreprises les
français découvrent internet en 1999 et
non pas dès 1995 comme nous mais ce
retard n'a aucune importance car le
monde d'internet de 99 n'a rien à voir
avec celui de 95
si bien que nous tous aux états unis en
france et dans le monde entier nous
construisons chaque jour un nouvel
internet
pourtant les patrons français niwat
encore qu'un gadget à la mode et n'ose
pas confier aux tuyaux d'internet ni
leurs secrets industriels ni leurs
transactions problèmes de
confidentialité
c'est pourquoi le gouvernement a pris le
risque contre l'avis des services de
sécurité d'autoriser le libre usage du
cryptage des données
jusqu'à présent il était quasiment
interdite en france de rendre un
déchiffrable les messages sur internet
des règles du jeu que nous fixerons qui
serait exclusivement limitée à la france
d'abord serait très vite contourné sa
part est certain et ensuite et surtout
serait pendant un certain temps un
handicap pour les entreprises françaises
un handicap aussi pour les consommateurs
et les citoyens français depuis toujours
seuls les militaires étaient autorisés à
coder leurs messages pour les citoyens
la législation française sur le
chiffrement et est l'une des plus
sévères au monde
c'est fini et c'est une authentique
révolution les décrets sont parus hier
au journal officiel
les logiciels de cryptage jusqu'à 128
bits sont désormais d' usage libre pour
tous les internautes
la france espère ainsi rattraper son
retard en matière de commerce
électronique votre liaison de rester
secrète